[Music]  we like to show clips that have been  that on YouTube that are popular this  one is too cute not to share it's a it's  a clip that everyone's talking about  it's a baby laughing hysterically as a  dog jumps around trying to heat bubbles  it's just fun  I'm training right now been up for four  straight days bring the Rockstar Energy  Drink like its water because I will not  rest until you're smooth what's that  sound  I'll take that beard and give it a  burial at sea and by burial at sea  I mean flush it down my toilet your  beard makes me vomit every time I look  at your beard it's like God is urinating  in my eyes you better sleep with one eye  open cuz I'm a second my straight razor  is gonna do the Lambada on your face  [Music]  [Applause]